hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen lektion 41 hört
zu und spricht nach
machst du oft sport
machst du oft sport ja ich spiele jeden
dienstag und donnerstag tennis ja ich
spiele jeden dienstag und donnerstag
tennis ja ich spiele zweimal pro woche
fussball
ja ich spiele zweimal pro woche fussball
ja ich mache oft sport ja ich mache oft
sport nein ich mache selten sport
nein ich mache selten sport hast du
kinder
hast du kinder ja ich habe eine tochter
ja ich habe eine tochter
ja ich habe zwei töchter
ja ich habe einen sohn
ja ich habe zwei söhne
nein ich habe keine kinder
was sind deine hobbys
ich spiele gitarre
ich fahre ski
ich mache gerne yoga
ich mache gern yoga ich lese gern ich
lese gern ich trainiere oft im
fitnesscenter
ich trainiere oft im fitnesscenter
ich mag fußball
ich mag fußball also was arbeitest du
als was arbeitest du
ich arbeite
als ingenieur
ich arbeite als ingenieur
ich habe einen neuen job als sanitär
ich arbeite momentan nicht
ich bin arbeitslos
ich bin arbeitslos was ist dein beruf
was ist dein beruf mein beruf ist lehrer
mein beruf ist lehrer
von beruf bin ich anwalt
hast du studiert hast du studiert nein
ich habe nicht studiert
nein ich habe nicht studiert ich habe
leder gemacht
ich habe
berufslehre gemacht
ja ich habe informatik studiert
studierst du an der universität
ja ich studiere medizin
nein ich studiere nicht nein ich
studiere nicht
ich mache eine lehre als mechaniker
ich mache eine
der als mechaniker
der kellner die kellnerin
was darf es sein
was möchten sie trinken was möchten sie
trinken was möchtest du trinken was
möchtest du trinken was kann ich ihnen
bringen
was kann ich ihnen bringen
was kann ich dir bringen
was möchten sie bestellen
der gast der gast
ich nehme einen
fe bitte ich nehme an
kaffee bitte ich möchte einen tee
trinken bitte
ich möchte einen tee trinken bitte
bringen sie mir ein wasser bitte bringen
sie mir ein wasser bitte mit oder ohne
kohlensäure mit oder ohne kohlensäure
mit kohlen
bitte mit kohlensäure bitte
ohne kohlensäure bitte
ich hätte gern einen orangensaft bitte
bezahlen sie zusammen oder getrennt
wir bezahlen getrennt bitte
kann ich mit karte bezahlen bitte
kann ich mit karte
zahlen bitte
wer hilft dir beim umzug
niemand hilft mir niemand hat zeit
niemand
hilft mir niemand hat zeit
kennst du schon deine neuen nachbarn
nein ich kenne sie noch nicht
nein ich kenne noch niemanden
der kühler
dank ist leer
der kühl
ist leer
es ist nichts mehr im kühlschrank
in definite
sachen alles etwas nichts
alles etwas nichts personen alle jemand
niemand
alle jemand niemand
allen jemanden niemanden
alle
jemandem niemandem
allen